Prince Harry is back in Canada this
morning reunited with his wife and his
young son Archie he arrived in Vancouver
overnight after what may have been his
last event as a senior royal Elizabeth
Palmer reports from Buckingham Palace
Prince Harry and yes he still gets to
use the title arrived in Vancouver last
night and was immediately whisked away
to rejoin Megan and eight-month-old
Archie
only hours before Harry had wound up his
job as a senior representative of the
royal family at a conference on African
investment Harry and Megan's exit likely
means even more work for Prince William
the future king who with his wife Kate
was on duty at Buckingham Palace for the
first time primary hosts of a reception
the previous day Harry had told a
meeting of his private charity that
there had been no option but to go we
all take a leap of faith so thank you
for giving me the courage to take this
next step but this is not yet a clean
break what are the loose ends while
there are more loose ends than there are
decisions the outstanding one of course
is the money who's gonna pay for what
and the probably the most outstanding of
all is the security keeping the young
family safe is going to cost a fortune
and British or Canadian taxpayers are
likely to get the bill that's going to
generate some anger on top of the
resentment already simmering most of it
directed at the outsider in this story
the British public opinion is that it's
all Megan's fault that she has lured
Harry away from us she is the one that's
insisted that they have a private life
now we should probably qualify that a
little bit it's a generational thing
older people here tend to feel as if
megan has lured Harry away but younger
people say look they deserve a chance at
a happy life and they just wish them
well Anthony all right still so many
questions Liz Elizabeth Palmer at
Buckingham Palace thank you I'm glad she
clarified because it doesn't look like
Harry's being lured to
I think this grew a joint decision
between the two of them even said it was
his decision yes he did say that in the
statement
you